all right this whole ordeal is quite
hypocritical of April Ryan who made a
name for herself at White House press
briefings demanding accountability
that's the president at any time thought
about stepping down before no and I
think that's absolutely ridiculous
question we're moving on Jordan go ahead
it's not ridiculous I let you rudely
interrupt me and your colleague I'm
gonna ask that you allow me to finish my
answer Sarah's bona surprise aren't
included with guys leave if we could go
on ahead because you choose not to call
me are you not going to answer that
though exposing all the Kenzie issues at
our community in America I'm going asked
about you'd have to answer me John go
ahead that's alright fine attack with me
now Sam Bungie no foxnews contributor
and Chris on former Chuck Schumer aide
and host of the aggressive progressive
podcast Dan
imagine if Sarah Sanders had treated
April Ryan the way April Ryan treated
this guy it's crazy
oh my god people be calling for Sarah to
be in handcuffs I know are you kidding
me do you understand Jessi
how embarrassing this story is so you
she works for a network April Ryan that
has promoted a baseless conspiracy
theory against the president for now
close to what two and a half years right
lies about the president while that
network complains about the president
being an enemy and the press they're
lying about while the same president
does Jesse have you ever you've been in
a bit Fox awhile have you ever seen a
president do as many pressors as this
guy every time he jumps on marine one he
answers 200 I know he's the most
transparent president we've ever had his
staff thinks he's too transparent while
they reply that goes out and man handles
a press guy for just setting up a camera
I mean the irony here is as thick as pea
soup it's really a bad Lucy Anna Chris
you know Jim Acosta someone sneezes and
he writes a book about how he's under
siege they have someone physically man
a reporter who's on their own team kind
of ideologically and they bury it and
don't want to talk about it pretend like
it never happened so I will say I'll
give you the point it was embarrassing
and I don't think that reporters have
been thrown out like that I don't know
the full situation I hope this was a
speech that had closed press or open
well you heard him say there were other
photographers there documenting the
speech I heard him I heard him saying it
but I don't know what the I don't know
the full story here and I don't think
you do either but I will point this out
you know there really is a big
difference between the President of the
United States and the press secretary
and a reporter giving a private speech
you guys understand the difference
between the president right who is I'm
just a porter giving a speech that might
have been a page beat you Jesse I don't
know if you know anybody's going to page
speech they usually have a contract that
says who can and cannot be there and
they're not open to the press okay well
it was open to the press because he was
the only known abilities and not having
I'm worried I'm wondering why that she
didn't want this guy there what was
April Ryan gonna say that was so secret
and so private I I know like April
Ryan's got like the nuclear football in
their back room and she was gonna be
proof yeah did she did you have edgy
material that she doesn't want to get
out there I mean come on I'm gonna tell
like more stories give me a break it's a
total joke at Chris come on listen if
you were in the political world I was in
the Secret Service world you know they
intersect we both done events
don't be naive about this you know this
was handled completely wrong you never
ever put your mitts on people steal
their stuff and then roughhouse a guy in
the lot I mean this is the biggest
rookie move ever see a movie to
seriously reevaluate a few guys these
embarrassing
I concede at that point mishandled but
good let me just answer Jesse's question
to you yeah when people give speeches
for a living they don't want them
recorded because they want to give that
speech somewhere else so that you know
what Chris
cereal I use I'm not gonna recycle stuff
to a different person speech I won't
kick you out I promise before we get to
the end I want to play a sound bite from
this MSNBC kook this is from the same
kook that accused the president United
States of raising and lowering the flag
according to Nazi numerology here's his
latest salvo against Trump supporters
rolling well this is why it's so
important to look through the lens of
radicalization when you look at this
president and and then apply counter
radicalization techniques he demands
that loyalty and they are loyal so if
you called from followers racist and
mass they simply coalesce around each
other and become even more defensive and
protective of the leader just as they
would in say a terrorist organization to
compare to the radicalization process
then the media just compared Trump
voters to terrorists yeah you know I
can't believe this guy is still allowed
on the air yeah this is the eight eight
a numerology astrology guy yeah who
found in the Gemini quadrant the sector
a white supremacist meeting yeah and the
half-staff lowering at the White House
how this guy is still on the air is
bizarre but Jesse the bigger story here
is not about Frank fuglie Z I mean an
FBI FBI who he's I think he's left FBI
should PR should tell this guy to stop
using their name it's really a story
about MSNBC who is willing to put
complete lunatics on the air who will
say absolutely anything at any time as
long as it makes Trump look bad Chris
that's what this is about
they've lost the momentum since the
Russia hoax evaporated that was run on
an entirely fake premise it was a
conspiracy theory the ratings have
suffered so now they keep on having to
put tin foil hat flamethrowers out there
so the audience gets their fix from
there the Trump derangement syndrome all
right look
that guy is a little kooky I will give
you that but that's your great tonight
you're conceding every point yeah
beep you can't paint the entire media
with a broad brush based on one analyst
what everybody on Fox News painted Fox
News by what I said weird hoots give me
a break listen I'm just saying
terrorists attack innocent people and
that's exactly what MSNBC is doing
they're attacking innocent American
that's the truth thing I'm just using
their words against all right let's
knock it off all right you can't be a
Nazi a sexist a racist and a terrorist
you know it's too much so stick to one
guys marry me you agreed with us twice
tonight by the way all right right now
we're gonna have him back now all right